From NPR, this is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantan. You don't need me to tell you that 2020 has been a year of change and disruption. The COVID-19 pandemic and the recession have upended many people's lives and will continue to do so in the months to come. So this year, for our annual U2.0 series about reinvention, we're focusing on the ways in which change comes into and out of our lives. We might not be able to control some of the things that happened to us, but we can shift the way we perceive and respond to them. I was really
这里是NPR的《隐藏大脑》，我是主持人香卡·维丹塔姆。不用我说，大家也知道2020年是充满变化与动荡的一年。新冠疫情和经济衰退颠覆了许多人的生活，这种影响在未来几个月还将持续。因此，在今年关于“重塑自我”的年度系列节目“U2.0”中，我们将重点探讨变化是如何进入并离开我们生活的。我们或许无法掌控发生在自己身上的一些事情，但我们可以改变看待和应对这些事情的方式。我当时真的
devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity, you know, I was first and foremost a violinist. Last and renewal, this week on Hidden Brain. My grandmother was an Indian classical violinist and so my mom had her old violin and arctic for many years. This is Maya Shankar. Each of my three older siblings had rejected the violin saying that it wasn't cool enough. And my mom finally gave me the instrument, and I was immediately taken kind of by the
因为失去了一件我深爱且充满激情的事物而感到崩溃，它曾是我生活和身份认同中非常重要的一部分。要知道，我首先是一名小提琴手。本周《隐藏大脑》的主题是“失去与重生”。我的祖母是一位印度古典小提琴手，所以我妈妈保留了她那把旧小提琴很多年。我是玛雅·香卡。我的三个哥哥姐姐都拒绝学小提琴，说它不够酷。我妈妈最终把这把琴给了我，我立刻就被那种
tactile sensation of the instrument. I mean the wood and the bow. I just loved the feeling of playing the violin. Even as a child, Maya immediately loved everything about the violin. The way it looked, the way it felt, the way it sounded. Maya's mother didn't know much about western classical music, but she signed up her daughter for lessons using the Suzuki method. The focus was on playing by ear and making beautiful sound.
触感迷住了。我是说，木头的质感和琴弓的感觉。我就是喜欢拉小提琴的感觉。即使在孩提时代，玛雅也立刻爱上了关于小提琴的一切。它的外观、触感和声音。玛雅的母亲对西方古典音乐了解不多，但她用铃木教学法为女儿报了名。教学重点在于通过听觉演奏，并发出美妙的声音。
Maya practiced constantly. I had a special scheduled school to lump all my classes together so that I could come a little bit early and get a little bit more practice in, and especially with all the traveling, most days were devoted exclusively to music. She got good, very good. Now the part of her music education that was missing was the formal part. She didn't know how to read music very well, but she had a fine ear, and she had ambition. In the pursuit to find a teacher who would take out to the next level, Maya's mother did something quite daring. Yeah, so my mom, she was really a go-getter when it came to my violin life because, like I said,
玛雅一直在练习。我有一个特殊的学校时间表，把所有课程集中在一起，这样我就能早点放学，多练一会儿琴。尤其是考虑到频繁的奔波，大多数时间都完全投入到了音乐中。她进步很快，非常好。现在，她音乐教育中缺失的部分是正规训练。她不太会看乐谱，但她有很好的乐感，而且很有抱负。为了寻找能带她更上一层楼的老师，玛雅的母亲做了一件相当大胆的事。是的，我妈妈在我的小提琴生涯上非常有进取心，因为正如我所说，
she didn't really have a lot of experience or exposure to the music community and kind of had to innovate in order to find opportunities. There were a New York one day close to the Juilliard School, one of the world's most famous and exclusive music institutions, when her mother came up with an idea. She said, Why don't we just go to Juilliard? I mean, why not, right?
她对音乐圈并没有太多经验或接触，为了寻找机会，她不得不进行创新。有一天，当她们在纽约靠近茱莉亚学院——世界上最著名、最顶尖的音乐学府之一——附近时，她妈妈想到了一个主意。她说：“我们为什么不直接去茱莉亚学院呢？”我的意思是，为什么不呢，对吧？
What can we lose? Just walk in the door. We just walked in. So we walked into the building and just by happenstance, we happened to run into a student in the elevator who studied with a music teacher. And my mom talked to that family in the elevator and said, would you mind if we just had about five or 10 minutes
我们有什么可失去的？直接走进去就行。我们就这样走了进去。纯属偶然，我们在电梯里碰巧遇到了一位学生，他师从一位音乐老师。我妈妈在电梯里和那家人交谈，说：“你们介意我们在你们的课程结束时，让玛雅为你们的老师演奏一下吗？”他们非常大度，说：“当然，没问题。”
at the end of your lesson where Maya could play for your teacher? And they were really gracious. And they said, sure, no problem. Of course, you know what happened next. Maya played for the other students for your teacher. And they were really gracious and they said, sure, no problem. Of course, you know what happened next. Maya played for the other students' music teacher, wowed the teacher, and got accepted into a summer program. Soon she was taking classes at Juilliard. She was playing with other talented musicians.
当然，你知道接下来发生了什么。玛雅为那位学生的老师演奏了，令老师惊叹不已，并被录取参加了一个暑期项目。很快，她就开始在茱莉亚学院上课了。她开始与其他有天赋的音乐家一起演奏。
She was even being featured on NPR. Joining us now is the Juilliard pre-college violin quartet. They are 17-year-old Emily Gendrun from Glassdenbri, Connecticut. 15-year-old Maya Shankar from Cheshire, Connecticut. Maya, by the way, is a from-the-top veteran. She's been with us since the early 50s. That was Maya on NPR's From-the-Top. She had found her classical music home.
她甚至还登上了NPR。现在加入我们的是茱莉亚学院预科小提琴四重奏组。她们是来自康涅狄格州格拉斯顿伯里的17岁女孩艾米丽·根德伦，以及来自康涅狄格州柴郡的15岁女孩玛雅·香卡。顺便说一下，玛雅是《From the Top》节目的常客。她从50年代初就开始和我们在一起了。那是玛雅在NPR《From the Top》节目中的表现。她找到了属于自己的古典音乐家园。
She was talented, hard hardworking, and the path before her seemed clear. I really wanted to be a violinist. I was so passionate about it. I never felt more comfortable than when I was performing. For some reason, that's where I experienced flow. And, you know, the ability to spend a lot of time practicing and trying to perfect the art and then you go on stage and you kind of just surrender and you play to the best of your abilities. There's just something beautiful and elegant about that process and I just really, really loved it. She was so good and so enthusiastic that opportunities kept presenting themselves.
她很有天赋，工作努力，前方的道路似乎很清晰。我真的很想成为一名小提琴手。我对此充满热情。我从未感到比在表演时更自在。出于某种原因，那就是我体验到“心流”的地方。而且，你知道，能够花大量时间练习并试图完善这门艺术，然后你走上舞台，你只是顺其自然，发挥出你最好的水平。这个过程有一种美丽和优雅，我真的非常非常喜欢它。她太优秀、太热情了，以至于机会不断涌现。
One day her teacher at Juliet arranged for her to play for a famous violinist, a very famous violinist. I nearly fell over in my seat because no reasonable musician thinks they're going to get the opportunity to meet its ok promen. Let alone play for its ok promen. Do you remember what you played? I played the barber violin concerto, played the first movement.
有一天，她在茱莉亚学院的老师安排她为一位著名的小提琴家演奏，一位非常著名的小提琴家。我差点从座位上摔下来，因为没有哪个理智的音乐家会认为自己有机会见到伊扎克·帕尔曼，更不用说为他演奏了。你还记得你演奏了什么吗？我演奏了巴伯的小提琴协奏曲，演奏了第一乐章。
["Parlman"] Paul Men decided to take her on as a student. In addition to Saturdays, I was also going to New York multiple times during the week, either for studio classes at his home in Manhattan or for private lessons or chamber music lessons, and at that point it was very clear to me that I wanted to become a concert violinist. Well I remember that she sounded, she had a very lovely, we're making music and that's for me a really the most important thing. To concert violinist Itsak Pearlman, it was okay that Maya had learned to play music by ear rather than by reading music.
帕尔曼决定收她为徒。除了周六，我每周还会多次去纽约，要么去他在曼哈顿家中的工作室上课，要么上私人课或室内乐课。那时我非常清楚，我想成为一名音乐会小提琴家。我记得她的声音，她有一种非常可爱的……我们在创作音乐，对我来说，这才是最重要的。对于音乐会小提琴家伊扎克·帕尔曼来说，玛雅通过听觉而不是看乐谱来学习音乐是可以接受的。
The technical stuff was important but it could be learned. You know, it's more important for me to have somebody musical. And let's say that the technique wise has, you know, you have to work on the technique, but the important thing is the music. And I felt that you had a very lovely way of phrasing and so on and so forth. And so we worked on that, but then we also worked on how to accomplish technically certain things. For example, in the Barbara concert, a little lost movement is a little bit tricky. So how do you practice that? But Pearlman didn't just teach Maya how to play the violin. He taught her something much more important.
技术方面很重要，但可以学。你知道，对我来说，拥有音乐感更重要。假设技术方面，你知道，你必须在技术上下功夫，但重要的是音乐。我觉得你在乐句处理等方面有一种非常可爱的方式。所以我们在这方面下了功夫，但也研究了如何从技术上完成某些事情。例如，在巴伯协奏曲中，最后一个乐章有点棘手。那么你如何练习呢？但帕尔曼不仅教玛雅如何拉小提琴，他还教了她更重要的东西。
How to teach herself to play the violin. I remember lots of lessons were, instead of telling me, my okay, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase. Here's what you should do to make it better. He would instead say, my, clearly you're unsatisfied with that phrase, what do you think you should do in order to make that phrase better? Let's talk about it. Let me hear what your aspirations are
如何教自己拉小提琴。我记得很多课程不是直接告诉我：“玛雅，显然你对那个乐句不满意。你应该这样做来改进它。”他反而会说：“玛雅，显然你对那个乐句不满意，你认为你应该怎么做才能让那个乐句更好？我们谈谈吧。让我听听你对这个乐句的构思。”
for the arc of this musical phrase. What tools do you have at your disposal, either with your bow arm or your vibrato or your tone, in order to make it beautiful, and it's really frustrating. I mean, in the moment you're thinking, okay, man, like you're the expert here, you know? Just tell me what to do. Please just tell me what to do and make this easier for both of us. So the more you learn, the more to think for yourself,
“为了让它变得优美，你手头有什么工具？无论是用你的运弓手臂、揉弦还是音色。”这真的很令人沮丧。我的意思是，在那一刻你心想：“天哪，你是专家，你知道吗？直接告诉我该怎么做。请直接告诉我该怎么做，让这对我们俩都轻松点。”所以你学得越多，就越要学会独立思考，
and to try and solve problems on your own, The better it is for you for the future. It was all going so well. When Maya was 15, she was practicing at a program run by its sock pro-men. And I was playing a passage from a very challenging Paganini Caprice. And I simply overstretched my finger on one note and I felt kind of a popping. And so I overstretched the tendon and it didn't really heal as expected. And so how did you spend the next months? What did you do? Well Mr. Prolman was such a gem because I injured my left hand. He continued to teach me violin just with my bow arm. So for over a year I went to him and we just worked on perfecting
并尝试自己解决问题，这对你的未来越有好处。一切进展得都很顺利。玛雅15岁时，正在参加一个由伊扎克·帕尔曼举办的项目。我当时正在演奏一段非常有挑战性的帕格尼尼随想曲。我只是在一个音符上过度伸展了手指，感觉到了一种“砰”的声音。我拉伤了肌腱，它并没有像预期的那样愈合。那么你接下来的几个月是怎么度过的？你做了什么？帕尔曼先生真是个宝藏，因为我左手受伤了，他继续只用我的运弓手臂教我拉小提琴。所以一年多来，我一直去找他，我们只是致力于完善
my bow arm and I would just play open strings in every lesson and he would teach me about how to produce a beautiful sound. You know, you always feel that it will resolve itself. So usually what happens if one hand doesn't particularly respond or anything like this, you work on the other hand just not to waste time just to do so. If you've got your left hand, there's a problem that you work on the right hand and vice versa. The attitude was obviously she wasn't, I mean, I'm sure that she was feeling good about it, but it was never like what's to use.
我的运弓手臂，我在每节课上都只拉空弦，他会教我如何发出美妙的声音。你知道，你总是觉得它会好起来的。所以通常发生的情况是，如果一只手没有特别的反应，你就练习另一只手，只是为了不浪费时间。如果你的左手有问题，你就练习右手，反之亦然。他的态度显然是……我的意思是，我相信她当时感觉不错，但从来没有说过“这有什么用”。
Maya's hand didn't heal. Doctors finally told her she had to stop playing completely. I was really devastated to lose something that I was completely in love with and so passionate about and that had really constituted such a large part of my life and my identity. I was first and foremost a violinist. And so I was anxious because I was worried that I would never find something that I felt as passionately
玛雅的手没有愈合。医生最终告诉她，她必须完全停止演奏。我真的因为失去了一件我深爱且充满激情的事物而感到崩溃，它曾是我生活和身份认同中非常重要的一部分。我首先是一名小提琴手。所以我很焦虑，因为我担心我再也找不到像对音乐那样充满激情的事物了。
about as I did with music. Just like that, Maya's dream to become a concert violinist was over. Back home for the summer in Connecticut, she started to ask herself how she could pick up the pieces, would she ever find anything that could make her as happy as the violin? To find out what Maya did, stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week we're looking at Loss and Renewal, with zeroing in on the unexpected moments in life that shift our trajectories. Before the break, a young violinist named Maya Shankar learned that she could no longer play her instrument because of an injury in her left hand.
就这样，玛雅成为音乐会小提琴家的梦想破灭了。夏天回到康涅狄格州的家中，她开始问自己该如何重拾碎片，她还能找到像小提琴那样让她快乐的东西吗？想知道玛雅做了什么，请继续收听。这里是《隐藏大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。本周我们关注“失去与重生”，聚焦于生活中那些改变我们轨迹的意外时刻。休息之前，一位名叫玛雅·香卡的年轻小提琴手得知，由于左手受伤，她再也不能拉琴了。
Up until this point, her whole life had revolved around music. Not knowing what else to do, Maya retreated to her parents' home in Connecticut. Her life felt in disarray. The summer before doctors basically told me I had to stop playing completely, and just by luck I was helping my parents clean their basement in Cheshire, Connecticut, and I stumbled upon an old coursebook of my sister's, it was called The Language Instinct by Stephen Pinker. My I started reading, and the more she read, the more excited she became.
直到那时，她的整个生活都围绕着音乐。不知道还能做什么，玛雅退回了父母在康涅狄格州的家中。她的生活感到一片混乱。那个夏天，医生基本上告诉我必须完全停止演奏，而就在运气使然下，我在帮父母清理柴郡家中的地下室时，偶然发现了我姐姐的一本旧课本，书名叫《语言本能》，作者是史蒂芬·平克。玛雅开始阅读，她读得越多，就越兴奋。
It was remarkable for me to learn about just how complex our minds were, and just what was required in order for us to have our day to day experiences. And so it really wet my appetite for learning more about the mind, and for exploring and more depth kind of the brilliance of the brain. She started to study cognitive science. She went on to get her PhD at Oxford on a Rhodes scholarship.
了解我们的思维是多么复杂，以及我们需要什么才能拥有日常体验，这对我来说非常了不起。它确实激发了我学习更多关于思维的知识，并更深入地探索大脑的辉煌。她开始学习认知科学。后来，她获得了罗德奖学金，在牛津大学攻读博士学位。
She got a postdoctoral fellowship, a promising career in academia lay ahead of her. But here again, came another unexpected turn. So over Thanksgiving break of the final year of my post-doc, I was at home and I was visiting my undergraduate advisor from college, named Laurie Santos, and she was telling me about the U.S. Department of Agriculture's efforts to get free and reduced price lunches, school lunches, into the hands of more eligible students. Students were going hungry because the process of getting certified for the lunch program was cumbersome.
她获得了博士后奖学金，学术界的前途一片光明。但在这里，又出现了另一个意想不到的转折。在我博士后最后一年的感恩节假期，我回家探望了我在大学时的导师劳里·桑托斯，她告诉我美国农业部正在努力让更多符合条件的贫困学生获得免费或减价的学校午餐。学生们因为申请午餐项目的过程繁琐而挨饿。
The Department of Agriculture came up with a simple idea. Instead of having a multi-step sign-up system, states could use information they already had about poor families to help enroll children in the lunch program. And it's just a matter of data matching and cross-enrolling these students. But as a result of this common sense reform, 12.4 million students, as of 2015, were automatically enrolled into the school lunch program and had access to lunches and were able to thrive at school.
农业部想出了一个简单的办法。各州不必使用多步骤的注册系统，而是可以使用他们已经掌握的关于贫困家庭的信息，帮助儿童加入午餐项目。这只是数据匹配和交叉注册这些学生的问题。但由于这项常识性的改革，截至2015年，有1240万学生被自动纳入学校午餐项目，获得了午餐，并能在学校茁壮成长。
And I remember being so moved by this example. To Maya, it was magical. It was just like a light bulb went off in my head and I thought, OK, this is what I need to be doing with my life. I want to be taking research insights from the behavioral sciences and allowing them to find their way into public policy so that they can be in the service of Americans and people around the world.
我记得被这个例子深深打动了。对玛雅来说，这很神奇。就像我脑子里亮起了一盏灯，我想：“好吧，这就是我余生需要做的事情。我想把行为科学的研究见解应用到公共政策中，这样它们就能为美国人和世界各地的人们服务。”
but they can be in the service of Americans and people around the world. So how do you break into the world of policy when you're just a lowly postdoc? Maya knew nothing of politics. She didn't have connections in the world of government. But she did remember a lesson her mother had taught her, standing outside the Jewel yard school, years earlier. She tracked down an email address for Thomas Kalea who was helping the Obama administration with its science policy. I sent Tom again a cold email. This is the Juilliard method again.
“它们能为美国人和世界各地的人们服务。”那么，当你只是一个卑微的博士后时，如何进入政策领域呢？玛雅对政治一无所知。她在政府界没有任何人脉。但她确实记得母亲多年前在茱莉亚学院门外教给她的那一课。她找到了托马斯·卡莱亚的电子邮件地址，他当时正在协助奥巴马政府制定科学政策。我再次给汤姆发了一封冷邮件。这又是茱莉亚方法。
This is my mom's Juilliard. I get to give her full credit for this. She is totally fearless and kind of inspired this trait. And I went over to his home and he asked me to pitch to him ideas that I had around interventions where behavioral science could improve public policy outcomes. What are you telling him? I talked to him about a number of things like the importance of
这是我妈妈的茱莉亚方法。我得把全部功劳归给她。她完全无所畏惧，某种程度上激发了这种特质。我去了他家，他让我向他推销我关于行为科学如何改善公共政策结果的干预想法。你告诉了他什么？我跟他谈了很多事情，比如
using social norms to motivate behavior. So we know from research that if you tell people that their neighbors use less energy than they do, right? They're more likely to use less energy. And there's a lot of domains in which just telling people what the data shows about people's actions and decisions can actually drive actions that are more in alignment with people's long-term goals or with policy objectives. And something that struck me about that conversation is I had been talking for years with my academic colleagues about the potential applications of using behavioral insights to improve people's lives.
利用社会规范来激励行为的重要性。我们从研究中得知，如果你告诉人们他们的邻居比他们用电少，对吧？他们更有可能减少用电。在很多领域，仅仅告诉人们关于他人行为和决策的数据，实际上就能推动与人们长期目标或政策目标更一致的行为。那次谈话中让我印象深刻的一点是，我多年来一直与学术同事讨论利用行为洞察力改善人们生活的潜在应用。
And this was the first time that when I told him an idea that I had his response was, oh, we can find a way to do that. Maya joined the White House. She was asked to put together a team that could marshal ideas from social science research and apply them to public policy challenges. So we have been working with the U.S. Department of Agriculture and also local school districts to redesign communications that they're sending to families to help promote the verification process so that their kids can stay on the benefit.
这是第一次，当我告诉他我的一个想法时，他的回应是：“哦，我们可以找到办法做到这一点。”玛雅加入了白宫。她被要求组建一个团队，将社会科学研究中的想法应用到公共政策挑战中。所以我们一直在与美国农业部以及当地学区合作，重新设计他们发送给家庭的通讯，以帮助促进验证过程，这样他们的孩子就能继续享受福利。
So we've done a few things. So there's a few behavioral insights that we've used. One is we've taken a very long list of action steps required for verification and condense them into three easy and understand steps that you can take. Two, we've worked with school districts to translate the communications into multiple languages in order to support comprehension among the diverse population that this program serves. One issue is that at present, families might only think the way to recertify or to verify
我们做了一些事情。我们使用了一些行为洞察力。第一，我们将验证所需的冗长行动步骤清单浓缩为三个简单易懂的步骤。第二，我们与学区合作，将通讯翻译成多种语言，以支持该项目所服务的多元化人群的理解。一个问题是，目前家庭可能只认为重新认证或验证
their information is to send snail mail back to the school district. And instead, there's the opportunity for them to take a picture of their information using their mobile phones and actually email it back. And we simply notified people of the opportunity to go through that process. And then in other instances, we included prepaid envelopes to help ease the process of verifying eligibility. So, I'm trying to think about why it is we often have trouble sort of thinking about programs like this because as someone who has been interested in human behavior for a while, it seems
他们信息的方式是寄平信回学区。相反，他们有机会用手机拍下信息并直接通过电子邮件发回。我们只是通知人们有这个机会。在其他情况下，我们附上了预付信封，以帮助简化验证资格的过程。所以，我试图思考为什么我们经常难以思考这类项目，因为作为一个关注人类行为一段时间的人，这对我来说
to me that programs like these really are, you know, no pun intended, a no brainer, that this is really something that we should be doing. It seems obvious that we should be doing it. But I think part of the issue is that I think many people might say, if you want to stay in a program that's giving you benefits, and these are the steps you need to do in order to get the benefits, and you deserve those benefits, rationally speaking, you should be willing to do those steps in order to get the benefits. And I think it fails to take into account the difference between how human beings are supposed to behave as rational
似乎……没有双关语的意思……是一个“不用动脑”的问题，这确实是我们应该做的事情。做这件事似乎显而易见。但我认为问题的一部分在于，我认为许多人可能会说：“如果你想留在给你福利的项目中，而这些是你为了获得福利需要做的步骤，并且你理应获得这些福利，从理性上讲，你应该愿意做这些步骤来获得福利。”我认为这未能考虑到人类作为理性生物应该如何表现
creatures and how they actually behave. And I feel like that's the central divide that your work is trying to bridge. And I think additionally, the onus is on the government to present information clearly, to present choices clearly, so that people understand what program exists and what their options are are and can make the best decisions for themselves and their families. But there's one example that I wanted to point to, which is a phenomenon known as summer
与他们实际表现之间的差异。我觉得这就是你的工作试图弥合的核心鸿沟。我认为此外，政府有责任清晰地呈现信息，清晰地呈现选择，以便人们了解存在什么项目以及他们的选择是什么，并能为自己和家人做出最好的决定。但有一个例子我想指出，那就是被称为“夏季流失”的现象。
melt. This is the phenomenon where talented high school students who are on track to go to college at the start of the summer, somehow lose their way and don't show up at college in the fall. Maya and her team have worked on simple, low-cost interventions that can help these students get to college. Their idea, send the students eight text messages over the summer reminding them of impending deadlines. What we found was a 9% increase in college enrollment rates. As a result of eight text messages,
这是指那些在暑假开始时有望上大学的优秀高中生，不知何故迷失了方向，秋季没有出现在大学。玛雅和她的团队研究了简单的、低成本的干预措施，可以帮助这些学生进入大学。他们的想法是：在暑假期间给学生发送八条短信，提醒他们即将到来的截止日期。我们发现大学入学率提高了9%。仅仅因为八条短信，
I mean that is really profound. Eight text messages is what I said my best friend on any given day. It seems to me that what you did and what happened to you is actually happens to lots of people all the time where doors close and they feel like it's unbearable that this door is closed because this is where I thought I lived. And then another door opens and you realize there are actually many, many houses in which we can live. I think that's exactly right. And I think, you know, one thing that violin, one of the great blessings of playing the violin is that it allowed me to see what it really felt like to be in love with something and to be really passionate about something. And so if anything you you see sort of features or
我的意思是这真的很深刻。八条短信是我在任何一天发给我最好的朋友的数量。在我看来，你所做的和你所经历的，实际上一直在很多人身上发生，门关上了，他们觉得这种关闭是无法忍受的，因为这是我以为我居住的地方。然后另一扇门打开了，你意识到实际上我们可以在许多许多房子里居住。我认为这完全正确。而且我认为，你知道，拉小提琴的一大福分是，它让我看到了深爱某物并对某物充满激情是什么感觉。所以如果有什么的话，你会看到在追求那个目标的过程中提取出的特质，然后你的希望是，在新的探索中，那些学科或领域能从你身上提取出同样的品质。我想知道，当你思考自己的人生时，你觉得你现在的职业已经定型了吗？这是你将永远居住的房子吗？另一方面，你是否真的相信，可能还有许多其他的房子？你终有一天会去居住。好吧，我当然从未比现在在公共服务部门工作并利用我的背景帮助改善人们的生活时更快乐。所以我认为这将继续成为我最终
traits that are extracted in you from engaging with that pursuit and then your hope is that in the new explorations those disciplines or those areas can extract those same qualities from you. I'm wondering as you think about your own life, do you feel that your career now has been set? This is the house you're going to live in forever. Do you actually believe, on the other hand, that they might be many other houses? You will one day come to live in. Well, I've certainly never been happier than I am right now working in public service and using my background to help improve people's lives. So I think that that will continue to be a common theme of whatever it is that I end up
所做和所从事工作的共同主题。话虽如此，我认为这种激情可以通过多种方式体现，对吧？我认为过去教会我的一件事是，世界有无限的机会来积极影响人们的生活。一路上，我可能会探索各种不同的路径来达到目标，但只要我坚持帮助人们和改善人们生活的核心价值，我认为有很多方法可以做到这一点。当然，你还有“冷呼叫茱莉亚方法”来帮助你。
doing and working in. That said, I think there are so many ways in which that passion can manifest, right? And I think that one thing the past has taught me is that the world has endless opportunities to positively impact people's lives. And along the way, I might explore various different paths in order to get there, but as long as I stick to that core value of trying to help people and improve people's lives, I think that there are many ways to do that. And of course, you have the cold-called Julia method to aid you.
是的。所以我认为，再次感谢我妈妈，我认为总有那种标准的“冷呼叫”万无一失的方法。那是玛雅·香卡。她曾在奥巴马总统任期内担任白宫科技政策办公室社会与行为科学高级顾问。此后，玛雅离开了白宫，成为谷歌首位行为洞察力负责人。现在，我们并非所有人都会成为音乐会小提琴家、罗德学者或总统顾问，但我认为这些都不是我故事的真正重点。我之所以想告诉你这个故事，是因为我们所有人的生活中都有章节
Yeah. So I think that, again thanks to thanks to my mom I think that there is always that foolproof method of the standard cold call. That was Maya Shankar. She served as senior advisor for the social and behavioral sciences at the White House Office of Science and Technology Policy on the President Obama. Since then Maya has left the White House and become Google's first head of behavioral insights. Now, not all of us are going to be concert via Linus or Rhodes scholars or presidential advisers, but I don't think any of those things are the real point of my story. The reason I wanted to tell you this story is because all of us have chapters in our lives
会结束，当它们结束时，特别是对于我们长期以来所知和所爱的章节，感觉就像整本书都结束了，没有什么可做的了，甚至可能没有什么值得活下去的了。但我认为我们每个人生活中的故事都反映了一个事实：今天的我们与几年前的我们已经不是同一个人了。我们在史密森尼学会人类起源项目工作。他是一位古人类学家，他说的一句话一直在我脑海中挥之不去。他告诉我，早期人类与其他物种的区别在于我们适应不同条件的非凡能力。
that close, and when they do, especially for the chapter we have known and loved for a long time, it can feel like the whole book is over, that there is nothing left to do, maybe even nothing left to live for. But I think each of us has stories in our lives that reflect the fact that the people we are today are not the same people we were a few years ago. We Parts at the Smithsonian Institution's Human Origins Program. He's a paleoanthropologist and something he said stuck in my head. He told me that the thing that distinguished early humans from other species was our remarkable capacity to adapt to different conditions.
独特的是，人类生活在非常寒冷的地方、非常炎热的地方、高海拔和海平面。我们中的一些人长期生活在水下甚至外太空中。这大部分与我们的身体能力无关，实际上与大脑有关。那句老话很有道理：当一扇门关上时，另一扇门就会打开。我想留给你们伊丽莎白·毕晓普的一首可爱的诗。歌手艾米·曼碰巧在NPR，我们请她为我们朗读这首诗。《一门艺术》，作者伊丽莎白·毕晓普。
Uniquely, humans live in very cold places, in very hot places, at altitude and sea level. Some of us live long periods underwater or even in outer space. Most of that isn't about our physical abilities, it's really about the mind. There's a lot of truth in that old saying, when one door closes, another opens. I want to leave you with a lovely poem by Elizabeth Bishop. Singer Amy Mann happened to be at NPR and we asked her to read the poem for us. One art by Elizabeth Bishop.
失去的艺术并不难掌握。这么多事物似乎都注定要失去，以至于它们的失去并非灾难。每天失去一些东西，除了慌乱，丢失的门钥匙，虚度的时光，失去的艺术并不难掌握。然后练习失去得更远，失去得更快，地点和名字，以及你打算去旅行的地方。这些都不会带来灾难。我失去了我母亲的手表。
The art of losing isn't hard to master. So many things seem filled with the intent to be lost, that their loss is no disaster. Lose something every day, except the fluster of lost door keys, the hour badly spent, the art of losing isn't hard to master. Then practice losing farther, losing faster, places and names and where it was you meant to travel. None of these will bring disaster. I lost my mother's watch.
看，我三个心爱房子中的最后一个或倒数第二个也去了，失去的艺术并不难掌握。我失去了两座可爱的城市，还有广阔的领土，我拥有的一些领域，两条河流，一个大陆。我怀念它们，但这并非灾难。即使失去你，那开玩笑的声音，一个我爱的姿态，我不会撒谎。显而易见，失去的艺术并不太难掌握，尽管它看起来，写出来，就像灾难。那是艾米·曼朗读伊丽莎白·毕晓普的《一门艺术》。艾米和泰德·里奥在NPR为《All Songs Considered》播客表演。本集由玛吉·彭曼和卡拉·麦格克-艾利森制作。团队包括珍妮·施密特、帕特·沙、雷娜·科恩、劳拉·夸雷尔、塔拉·博伊尔、托马斯·
And look, my last or next to last of three loved houses went, the art of losing isn't hard to master. I lost two cities' lovely ones, and Vastor, some realms I owned, two rivers a continent. I missed them, but it wasn't a disaster. Even losing you, the joking voice a gesture I love. I shant have lied. It's evident the art of losinguzin's not too hard to master, though it may look like, write it, like disaster. That was Amy Mann, reading one art by Elizabeth Bishop. Amy was at NPR with Ted Leo to perform for the All Songs Considered Podcast. This episode was produced by Maggie Pennman and Cara McGurk-Allison. A team includes Jenny Schmidt, Parts Shah, Raina Cohen, Laura Quarelle, Tara Boyle, Thomas
刘和凯特·舒格内特。本周的无名英雄是帮助我重塑自己生活的人。保罗·金斯伯格是一位长期的NPR支持者。2013年12月，他找到我，告诉我我不应该只做每周的广播故事。他问：“做一个播客怎么样？”保罗不仅仅是提出了一个想法。他帮助它成为了现实。他筹集资金帮助启动了《隐藏大脑》，从那时起他一直是一位值得信赖的朋友和顾问。除了时间和金钱，保罗给了我可能是最宝贵的
Liu and Kat Shugnet. A run-song hero this week is someone who helped me reinvent my own life. Paul Ginsberg is a longtime NPR supporter. In December 2013, he came to me and told me I should be doing more than just weekly stories for radio. What about a podcast he asked? Paul did more than just simply toss out an idea. He helped to make it a reality. He raised funds to help launch Hidden Brain and he's been a trusted friend and advisor ever since. More than time and money, Paul gave me what might be the most valuable
礼物，一个人可以给另一个人的礼物。他帮助我看到了我自己没有看到的东西。谢谢你，保罗。更多关于《隐藏大脑》的内容，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上找到我们。如果你喜欢这一集，一定要看看我们本月在播客和广播节目中播出的其余“U2.0”系列节目。我是香卡·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。
gift one person can give another. He helped me see something in myself that I had not seen on my own. Thanks Paul. For more hidden brain, you can find us on Facebook and Twitter. If you liked this episode, be sure to check out the rest of our YouTube.0 series, all this month on the podcast and radio show. I'm Shankar Vedantum, and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一个人能给予另一个人的礼物。他帮助我看到了我自己未曾发现的一面。谢谢你，保罗。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请务必查看我们YouTube系列节目的其余部分，本月将在播客和广播节目中持续播出。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。